nothing i've ever had before
brazil you know what you're going oh
look at that
i love it this looks delicious holy moly
hi cuba knows what they're doing
now we gotta go to greece smells
delicious are you hungry yet
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okay's mom
and if your family is anything like mine
you might be a little sick of cooking
the same five or six meals on rotation
every week
so i want to shake things up i want to
get a little international food going in
this house
so i'm going to ask my instagram
followers to submit their very favorite
recipe from all over the world
i'm going to compile those and cook
those for my family for an entire
week i hope i do them justice and i hope
they taste delicious so
wish me luck the reason i'm doing this
is i want my kids to grow up with an
international palette i want them to be
accustomed to different seasonings and
spices
i don't want my kids to be the a-hole at
the lunch table at school
teasing another kid for the food that
they're eating so some of these recipes
are family recipes
and are secret so i can't share them but
the ones that i do have i will link in
the description
and finally a warning this video will
make you hungry
so don't watch it if you haven't eaten
yet do not watch this on an empty
stomach
the food is delicious i'm having a
surprisingly easy
time finding these ingredients there are
a couple of seasonings that i've
never tried before in my life i got so
many good
food suggestions so this is going to be
very exciting so day one we're going to
cuba i'm making
ropa vieja so i'm starting with some
flank steak
it raises for a long time so i need to
get started kind of early
ropa vieja is a dish with shredded meat
and veggies that is simmered in a tomato
sauce with
lots of amazing pickley foods added to
it i have some really fun stuff to add
to this like
pimentos i say it like pimentos but it
might be
pimientos pimentos i am single-handedly
going to finish this entire can of
olives
before uh oh hold on
hold on hey hey i saw that wyatt
apologize don't kick dirt either capers
oh my gosh i'm so excited for this food
i boiled the beef
in a stock and then shredded it and then
threw it in our delicious
sauce all right we're simmering cute
mess
here she is with
rice this dish was a smash hit
what do you think it looks yummy the
boys loved it i knew that wyatt would
really like this dish because he loves
bell peppers and he loves beef
so i really wanted to start out with
something that would
introduce him to newer foods with some
familiarity
delicious it's good
does it get a thumbs up from you
excellent perfectly salty the beef was
this
amazing texture oh yeah
did you like it is it good
[Music]
i wanted to make sure that i did a good
job and i did the recipe justice
so i actually sent a photo to the girl
who sent me the recipe
they said i did great they said it
looked amazing today
it's time to give canada some love we
are making
poutine i don't know why i have butter
out shout out to my canadian follower
who sent me the recipe
i was very excited to try this
so the base of poutine is french fries
and cheese curds
smothered in gravy the one thing i don't
have is cheese curds but the recipe came
with a substitution we're gonna use
mozzarella
and i have some fries in the oven and
let's get started on the gravy i have my
butter a butter
i'm going to add my flour
and i have some cornstarch slurry my
friends that means it's corn starch and
water mixed together gonna thicken my
gravy this gravy is very
simple it's a mixture of chicken and
beef broth okay
i gotta bring this to a boil stir it
with a whisk then i'm gonna add my
cornstarch slurry and that's
literally it so easy jackson is helping
me with the mozzarella cheese
henry's doing his thing why is his hair
don't mind my messy kitchen just don't
look at it okay
let's get this gravy on it smelled
heavenly
how's it taste good that's good you
think you'll clean your plate
[Music]
how could you not be excited about
cheese gravy and fries
poppies
oh man it was amazing
this is like the happiest comfort food i
sent a picture to my follower i was
nervous about the crinkle fries but my
followers said that it really didn't
matter if i used crinkle and so
they said i did a great job i'm making
dessert today
i'm making brazilian brigadeiros what
are brigadeiros
well they were suggested by this lovely
follower of mine
and they are a brazilian dessert they're
very easy they're only five ingredients
and so sign me up for that this is the
labor
of love you just have to continuously
stir it basically you just stir this
until it thickens up you don't want it
to burn on the bottom
and then you let it cool to room
[Music]
temperature
[Music]
hot okay i don't know how anybody has
the patience to wait to roll these into
balls i'm
just out of the plug it's so good
there's not gonna be any left for my
children we have
our cooled brigadeiro i'm gonna butter
my hand
oh my gosh this might be too warm still
can i do this ah oh gosh
good luck i either took it off the stove
too soon or didn't chill it long enough
and when i went to start rolling the
balls with the kids
everything was just flattening back out
into a pancake i need to
chill this longer so let's give it a try
oh yeah this is much better oh yeah
are you sure fun to make though aren't
they it's always really exciting when i
try something
that my tongue has never tasted before
and it was creamy and a little salty
and perfectly sweet and so chocolatey
this is heaven brazil
you know what you're doing amazing
so good the boys love them they've asked
to make them since
we will continue to make these at home
because it's a really special
delicious dessert all right now let's
have dinner i failed today
everybody's asleep and i just got
carried away from the day and didn't
have any time to cook
but i have so much stuff that my fridge
is full
and i literally have to make this food
because i don't have room in the fridge
for it
day four is thanks to my follower in
greece
who sent me a beautiful recipe for spani
copida
this dish is very near and dear to my
heart and i'm very familiar with it
because growing up we had a neighbor
from greece
hi ho who would make it all the time for
us for special occasions and it was one
of our favorite foods
the first thing i have to do is lay the
phyllo dough on my pan
still have to oil the edges a little bit
it's kind of oh
shoot that's what i wasn't supposed to
do oh i wasn't supposed to tear it
it's really crazy cool though it's like
paper i've never worked with filo dough
before
which is kind of surprising i cooked
down my spinach with some herbs and
leeks i added my feta and i put that on
my bottom crust of filo dough
here's my dilemma she says brush on
two beaten eggs brush them over the
spinach i don't have a brush
it's in the oven and it's gonna bake for
one hour
and it is 10 15. this is not a dish you
start
at 9 30 p.m now the temptation
of this crispy brown gold and phyllo
dough was too much
for me and i learned the hard way
to not taste food straight out of the
oven
i think this will be the key to getting
white to like spinach i really do
i had high hopes that sandwiching it in
this crust would make wyatt's day
i'm pretty impressed
i love it how's that crunch good
you like it
[Music]
it tastes exactly like i remember it
[Music]
it was flaky it was juicy in the middle
it was salty but also
super savory and oh it was so good
[Music]
that's amazing everybody was a huge fan
i sent a picture to my follower they
said i did a great job
i really hope people aren't just being
nice and not wanting to hurt my feelings
but it did look pretty accurate
now we got to go to greece tonight is
indian food i am so excited now day five
dish
came from this follower in india and the
recipe
is for pav bhaji i feel like a lot of
indian cuisine
is passed down through generations and
it's a lot of word of mouth
and watching somebody cook in the
kitchen and i
didn't want to mess it up so intimidated
so i boiled my potatoes
i sauteed several vegetables forever
and i added my spice blend i ordered
this masala um it
wasn't difficult to get it wasn't
difficult to find i just got it on
amazon and it was delivered in two days
now stupid me didn't think through the
process of cooking this and i should
have gotten a masher but i
didn't so i'm trying to mash these
vegetables with a fork
why won't you mash all right we are
getting there
in the end the texture was slightly
chunkier than i had hoped it would look
like
but it was pretty smooth and smooth
enough to dip the bread in
and use that as the utensil holy moly
oh that's good this was a smash
hit oh you got it with your fingers
[Music]
isn't it delish so good also going
through this week
i'm so proud of the boys for their
open-mindedness with new foods
and their willingness to try new things
it really goes to show
that if kids are presented with the
opportunity they will be open-minded and
they will try something new i sent a
picture to my follower who sent me this
recipe and they said that it looked
great
i am prepping my chicken adobo
day six we are headed to the philippines
in our
stomachs special thanks to this follower
who sent me the recipe
and helped me all the way through i have
chicken thighs
and i'm going to add soy sauce garlic
peppercorns
bay leaves sugar vinegar
i think that's it all right this looks
and smells amazing i'm gonna marinate
this for
a couple hours it's time to
sear my chicken i was so surprised that
so few
ingredients when combined made this
amazing
smell in my kitchen okay this looks and
smells
amazing it's such tender chicken
oh my god i need another bite
that was so freaking good oh my god
try the chicken honey
is it good yeah oh my god
it's so good 10 out of 10.
this dish went over so well with
everybody it was
tasty flavorful and just tasted
so complex when it was really only a few
simple ingredients
i'm so happy it's so good i sent a photo
to my followers they said i did a good
job they said i did it right
yeah all right it is time to turn up the
heat
day seven i decided to go for a big
finish and made
doubles from trinidad this was suggested
by this follower
in trinidad whose uncle actually owns a
restaurant in new york
that serves doubles all right there were
a couple substitutions i had to make
because i could not source the
ingredients
one is for the green seasoning which is
really important for flavor
i had to get a jarred like herb
puree and then i had to get jarred
pimentos pimientos pimentos i don't know
how to say it now the chana mixture
is dried chickpeas split peas
onion cherry pepper baking soda
salt and that's it so far i'm going to
bring it to a boil and then
it's really important that you skim the
foam off as it's cooking
my foam is starting to get there so
she's a foam lady she's
getting the foam off it's time to add my
green seasoning and
some turmeric it said your dish will
turn a burnt orange color
do not be alarmed so it's time to make
the dough and you heard that right i
said make
the dough from scratch it's a very
simple dough mixture
there's a little bit of turmeric that
gives it a golden color
jackson is helping me he's getting the
yeast
is this yep that's right now don't spill
it get it over into our
bowl
you know what i see that yeast
skirt
[Music]
i have my dough it's very stretched i
don't know what
size exactly i'm supposed to do you want
to fry it for only a couple seconds you
don't want to fry it to golden brown
you want to fry it so it's still pliable
all right i feel like i'm
slowly getting the hang of this oh no oh
my gosh and then i do that
okay this looks mighty close it's soft
you can fold it
it's perfectly fried i
think this looks really good so the
channel was simmered
and tender and delicious and the bar was
fried and ready to go
it's usually served with two pieces of
bara
and covered in the chana oh boy
okay this smells incredible
this looks incredible are you kidding me
it's like nothing i've ever had before
it's like a flavor explosion
oh it was so good
[Music]
i love it how is it amazing
10 out of 10 10 out of 10.
ten out of ten it was delicious it was
fantastic
it's worth the work it's worth the
effort a thousand times
it was amazing yum yum yum you want more
yum yum this is legitimately one of the
best things i've ever tasted in my life
now the true test was to send the photo
and get a stamp of approval
they were so kind they were so
encouraging they said i nailed it they
said it looked great
and they said i did a good job so after
this week
i set out to expand my kids minds and
get them more
exposed to different flavors and i think
that
we did it we did a good job of it my
instinct as a parent sometimes
is to make food more mild for them
because
their kids their palate is more
sensitive and that is so
wrong they want to try flavor they want
to try new foods
and so it was really exciting to see
them embrace these other cultures
embrace these other foods and i think it
makes them better people
so that's it for now i'm hannah and if
you want us to do another
version of this episode of part two make
sure to message me on instagram
or feel free to just send me your
favorite recipes because i'm so down to
try it
and if you'll please excuse me we have
to head back from our walk because we're
gonna go home and make
more brigadeiros till next time
[Music]
show them how you walk
[Music]
desert kids
[Music]
you